doj sues musk SpaceX for Refugee
discrimination
this is the Biden Administration
targeting their political opponents why
because Elon Musk bought ax Elon Musk is
allowing people to come back he's
allowing people to speak they can't stop
him they'll try and destroy him I got
this tweet from Elon
somebody tweeted uh Tom Muller said
so if I let a non-us citizen see our
rocket Hardware I go to itar jail
but if I don't hire a non-us citizen I
get sued by the doj got it Elon Musk
says SpaceX was told repeatedly that
hiring anyone who is not a permanent
resident of the United States would
violate International arms trafficking
law which would be a criminal offense we
couldn't even hire Canadian citizens
despite Canada being a part of NORAD
this is yet another case of the
weaponization of the doj for political
purposes and he is 100 correct Elon Musk
is stepping out in front of the machine
and they are pissed off about it and so
now he is being sued in the most
psychotically imaginable that he hired
too many American citizens this is crazy
because look at Nasa they're not doing
anything right now compared to SpaceX
right so they're going to hamper SpaceX
and take one of the most you know
successful space-faring companies in
recent memory they're going to hamper
them well you know there's a handicap
I'll tell you what the real issue is the
real issue is that the doj knows that if
Elon Musk actually builds Starship it's
going to crash into the firmament
exploding exposing the Earth as fled
yeah wait wait wait wait chaos
come on I am kidding
he's gonna get to the end of the planet
do you believe in Flat Earth
's not oh okay yeah of course that's the
joke okay
there's no way
now now the ice wall is the difference
we were arguing because I know like I
keep I have these friends who are like
then why can't you go to Antarctica Tim
and I'm like you can you can literally
go to Antarctica like there's this weird
thing where they're like if the Earth
was round then why wouldn't why don't
they let us go to Antarctica I'm like
some dude filmed himself marching
through Antarctica bro it's just you got
to get a permit for it they think
there's like like government agents
guarding the end of the Earth well
they're right they literally they flat
earthers thing not all of them that if
you get too close to the edge of Flat
Earth there's armed ships that will stop
you they're gonna reassign Trump's
Secret Service after he goes to jail and
send them to the end of the Earth I'll
be completely fair you need a permit to
go to Antarctica yes it's controlled by
various military groups I think there's
like 14 Nations that have territory
there okay and it's just it's yeah
because it's scientific research and
strategic location that's uninhabited if
you can show up on a cargo ship doing
the supply delivery and then like go on
the shore and like look at the Penguins
and stuff like that tons of people do
these little tours you're there for a
few hours and you leave if you want to
do an extended thing you just have to
let the other countries know because it
would be like
entering Russia without a Visa and so
because of that they're like then why
won't they let you go and I'm like bro
you can't go to Russia without a permit
they're not the Earth isn't flat because
Russia is requiring you know visas I
just love the idea though that there's
like a secret conspiratorial Battalion
guarding the edge of the of Flat Earth
so that anyone who gets too close at any
point of the Flat Earth they stop you
like dude there's no secret cabal wow
dedicated to protecting the firmament
where all that black budget money is
going gotcha I've never heard the black
the flatter Theory so this is all new to
me oh this is something I haven't I
haven't we have friends that believe in
it I don't know why but yeah once again
to be fair I've I like
you know I've not gone to outer space
and looked at the Earth so you know but
there's a whole bunch of other reason
why the Flat Earth stuff is just stupid
but it is the Earth is real your other
conspiracy is also wacky as well which
is funny enough yeah well hilarious the
Earth is uh
it's actually uh flat and Hollow I was
gonna say what about Hollow Earth that's
what we really should be talking about
no like this is the real conspiracy
going on Earth see everybody keeps
saying if the Earth is flat and there's
the other one the Earth is hollow I
think it's flat and Hollow it's a donut
a donut okay that's a donut donut Earth
theory which you can't tell wait so
there'll be other people donut holes in
the earth is just a regular donut would
it be crazy though if the Earth was
actually a donut like you are hanging
out in your city on the inner ring and
you look up and you see Chicago yeah
that'd be so weird
Halo you believe in aliens Tim I mean I
believe alien life is possible but
whether or not there's intelligent alien
life roaming around I don't know a lot
of people did until the government said
they were real no I love that the meme
that's like conspiracy theorists in you
know 1990 and it's like aliens are real
yeah right regular person oh shut up no
they're not conspiracy there 2023
regular person aliens are real
conspiracy there's no they're not yeah
they now they're the opposite yeah
anyway back to what we're talking about
though yeah they're going after Elon
they want to shut down anybody who like
they want to cause Financial harm to
anybody who's helping them out here's a
guy who put Trump back on Twitter
Trump's making a lot of money off that
yeah they're pissed
how are you supposed to stop Trump if
Elon Musk is giving him this massive
platform they try to take away from him
before before Elon had it Trump was
banned off everything I thought he was
allowed back on Facebook or something
recently yeah his band expired or
something it was like two years they're
like okay fine yeah but we can see a
formula that happens with people that
they want to be quiet basically to
cancel your accounts yeah for example
social media bank accounts as well and
then they go through your family and
then put you in jail the next premium
like death pretty much I like the idea
that like they go after Trump for
listing his weight as incorrect they're
like you lied on a government document
you are not 215 pounds that's BS yeah
and I could tell you from experience
like when you book somebody in you don't
put them on a scale you just ask them
how much do you weigh and they'll tell
you like okay Trump's like seven feet
tall yeah they're like you got a boss
yeah like you just like when you intake
them you're like no whatever I'm gonna
just write it down it's like okay maybe
right before he got booked yeah maybe
eight like you typically made a question
because like the women always come in
and they lie I'm 100 pounds you're like
he's like lady I've seen you got four
chins yeah I've seen like three separate
hundred pounds they all look different
yeah yeah like what the hell all right
right you go on a date how tall are you
six feet come on man I mean yeah
rounding up yeah but but now they have
those high heels for guys you've seen
those right oh yeah those uh those shoes
oh yeah contouring whatever I don't know
what they're called there's a knee
surgery too yeah surgery
the the leg surgery stuff is messed up
they break your legs apart but they sell
shoes that have inserts so it makes you
two and a half inches taller yeah this
everything is depressing so just to
think about this is the temple exclusive
just so you guys know
they also ask a question what's fresh
what's your height and with these shoes
I'm six feet oh these are um
uh Alexander McQueen's but those are
just like normal shoes with a thick soul
but they have a huge platform yeah
bottom but they're I would say those are
as close as you can get without being
platforms yeah yeah yeah like it's a
thick Soul it probably gives you an inch
or something yeah pretty much but they
have these they have those shoes with
those things or you you buy those Santa
yeah you're right it does you just need
to like learn to accept it like I'm I'm
basically can get like four inches of
height out of that surgery or something
like that yeah I'm like I'm five five
I'm super short I'm like imagine the
embarrassment of like paying all that
money just to be no just to be the
height of the average American male yeah
like Brew just find something else that
works for you and yeah
that people are doing this kind of stuff
all this weird it's the male BBL well
again but it's social media influence
man absolutely yeah pretty much so this
is instead of going the route of dating
we'll go to the route of transhumanism
on the conversations right we can talk
about guys wanting to hook up and doing
anything to do it and women getting
surgery but there's also people want to
be things they're not guys want to be
tall but they're not tall they want to
be more desirable or some people want to
be a carrot some people want to be a
kangaroo some people they're they're
like there was that tiger man I'm not
Chris identify as a lawnmower yeah
that's right on our show sometimes
honestly bro like I like it I love grass
multiple people who get this that's
allowed who get the super realistic dog
costumes and then go walk around the
park yeah like oh there's that one guy
doing that in the car there's two of
them there's a guy it is a wolf and a
guy who did it as a border collie
which is going to be weird dude no it's
it's weird bro we got one of those VR
things where it's a treadmill we haven't
set it up yet we just got it you strap
yourself in and there's this bowl you
stand on you put on your VR headset and
when you try to run the harness holds
you in place and your feet cause you and
VR to move so you can actually move
around 360 degrees and run while in VR
on this treadmill thing people are going
to strap themselves into this the moment
that moment becomes cheap enough for the
average household and they're not going
to go in the real world anymore actually
we had a guy on the show spoke about VR
only fans we're basically you go into
this world and any girl you want to
think of AI generated yes but the only
thing is though you can create your
avatar or create the girl perfect go for
you and it actually items you can use to
have that same feeling in the real world
so you can do your thing with the only
fans girl in a room it's going to be so
creepy metaverse basically you can pay
for it well I'm saying only fans is
going to go out of business yeah because
guys like
it's going to be a bunch of dudes AI
generating porn for other dudes yeah or
for themselves yeah and they're going to
be able to get that's that's also
interesting that they want the future is
going to be gross it's going to be
strange yeah but you know what if they
let guys if they let the you know the
Transformers into WNBA then you know we
might actually watch the WNBA they'll be
able to dunk and stuff like oh okay I'll
watch them two WNBA uh women
players Brittany Greiner one more
one more the worst trade is nobody knows
you're a Casey plumber what's her name
Las Vegas uh yeah hold on and one more
because Brittany Greiner is the free
space it's like name two NBA star wnb
stars outside of Britain oh cool yeah
yeah one more yeah because everyone
knows her for them she went to jail
people know that one is because she's
the lady who threw the the shirts like
the top level of the stadium so they
made a big deal about it because she
threw like a basically the equivalent of
like an average NFL players and we
traded her for The Merchant of death
Victor who we spent a ridiculous amount
of money to prosecute yeah I know one
Sarah Harrison see there you go I got
two would you you sure
I did not look that up I made the name
up knowing you guys wouldn't know
the guys go around and he goes he goes I
will give you one dollar or two tickets
to a WNBA game and everybody takes the
dollar yo I mean bro I don't sound like
a jerk but I mean female sports like who
cares
UFC MMA women's MMA I watch that it's
good it's good I mean I I could give you
that but it's like all other female
sports is like who's there like you know
happy dads and parents yeah go ahead and
here's the thing I'm I'm off for female
sports because I think it's good that it
keeps uh women away from doing bad
things in their adolescent years right
and if I have a daughter God forbid I'm
gonna put them in sports right but like
professional female sports bro nobody
cares like this crazy purple hair chick
what's her name that wants to equal
people yeah whatever her name is she
doesn't want equal pay she wants a
renegotiated contract because they
negotiated their contract in the first
place so apparently they're like two pay
structures more money up front less
bonus or less money up front more bonus
and they negotiated a contract that
chose one over the other which meant
that they got paid less in the short
term than the men and they were like hey
look they're getting paid more than us
a smart move is good business I have
more power to him here I'm gonna here
you go uh Brittany Grinders are given
she's six foot nine dude that's she's
tall Sue bird oh yeah there you go I
feel like I feel like mostly in the name
right yeah bird is like the most famous
one I still couldn't remember it but I
know that that's a problem
I'm from uh Connecticut and she played
for UConn's good I've heard of her
before but I couldn't uh Delle Donne not
off the top of my head though that's
that's the truth you know what's crazy
though like like a good high school
men's basketball team can probably beat
a WNBA team oh yeah well for sure like
that they can probably be like the like
what 15 year olds beat the women's
soccer team yeah they're like yeah the
national team like it's it dude I just
want to be honest though like
the thing about basketball I don't like
there are a lot of really really good
players like Steph Curry genuine
legitimate top tier Talent one of the
best the best legend legendary I watched
a video and it said when you're so good
you can tell when the floor is broken
and he's dribbling and then he stops and
he looks and he points at the floor and
he just knows because he understands so
well I'm like it's amazing but I saw
that video yeah right there are players
who are just tall it's like you are on
the team because you're 7-3 thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time